[Music]
what does it mean for a world to have
died does it have to be desolate does it
have to lie in Ruins or could it be
beautiful still rich with green still
haunted by the rare remaining life form
I ask these questions because the game
Greece is quite possibly the most
visually breathtaking thing I've ever
played the world is incredible the
colors the creatures the Landscapes it's
all
so
alive which is important because I
believe the world of Greece is a world
that has
[Music]
died when we think of dead worlds we
typically don't think of beauty this is
especially true for video games where
the word dead usually implies a setting
is lacking in meaningful content
but I want to challenge this assumption
to explore environments that are
spectacular and filled with artistic
Merit yet are in their own ways dead for
sometimes the end of a world is just the
beginning speaking of which Greece
begins with the end of the world the
protagonist living in a landscape of
color Upon A mysterious stone hand finds
this realm collapsing around her falling
through the sky she descends all the way
to the surface where nothing remains but
a monochrome desolate expanse from here
the world is split into five sections
that reflect the five stages of grief
each region is further centered on a
dominant color with gray representing
the initial Detachment of denial
recovering from the fall you wander
through a graveyard of Bleak ruins
perhaps wreckage from the recent
Calamity or perhaps remnants from an age
lost to time the environments of Greece
are not meant to be completely literal
the external desolation often a symbolic
representation of the main characters in
our
sorrow the opening of Greece can be
better understood in conversation with
this other game about personal loss
personified on a vast and personal scale
Shadow of the Colossus is the kind of
title that looms over the entire medium
the iconic story of a lone Warrior
defeating 16 ithin to bring a loved one
back to life the game does not at a
glance take place in a dead world I mean
there are giant creatures wandering
around in it hard to get more alive than
that right yet the Forbidden lands the
Forgotten cursed region where the game
takes place somehow manag to feel blank
the kind of blankness that Hollows you
out it takes so long to travel to each
Colossus that the Towering Giants start
to seem hopelessly minuscule next to the
Bleak enormity of the land itself
there's an argument to be made that this
feeling of blankness was even more
profound in earlier versions of the game
due to limited graphical detail but even
in the remastered version the wrongness
of this land is unmistakable like this
is a world that life has forsaken though
often beautiful it is in its own way a
dead world but Shadow of the Colossus
has more in common with the first stage
of Grease than just its setting it is
also quite overtly a story about denial
it is clearer from the opening sequence
that this deal the main character has
struck to resurrect their loved one is
extremely dodgy and yet it's easy for
both the protagonist and the player to
ignore any feelings of unease because
there are monsters to fight but as the
game wears on you start to think more
and more about how most of these
creatures only become aggressive if you
attack attack first I'm far from the
first person to make this point but
because of the environment's baress
you're left alone with your thoughts
between each battle this makes it harder
to hide from the fact that you're
extinguishing some of the last remaining
beings in this world all because you
can't let go of a personal
loss if you return to a spot where you
slew a Colossus you will find their
bodies have become part of the landscape
the surroundings Sweeping in to reclaim
these last vestiges of life it is
impossible when exploring these remains
to hide from the reality of what you've
done though you like the protagonist
want to keep denying that the world
their world is really dead the
physicality of these bodies make the
truth of bereavement
undeniable it's not clear at first whom
the protagonist of Greece is grieving
for but it is clear she is grieving for
someone who is Central to her emotional
World their significance quite literally
ly embodied in the Colossal statues
littered throughout the land that
disintegrating hand in the opening
represented their passing yet they stood
so tall in the protagonist life that
their remains continue to shape the
environment long after their
death the way death Alters the
Landscapes of these games reminds me of
a real natural phenomenon when a whale
swims its last the carcass will
sometimes sink all the way to the ocean
floor and create something called a
whale
the impact of a whale fall on the
Abyssal ecosystem is well colossal a
single carcass can bring more organic
material to the seafloor than 200 years
of nutrients falling from the surface
like grief whale fall Falls too can be
divided into specific stages in the
initial scavenger stage specialized
foragers pillage the Leviathan from all
directions after playing Shadow of the
Colossus I think I kind of know what
that feels like for the next 2 years the
whale's remains will become animated
with movement a tumultuous new ecosystem
formed from the remains of a dead
one the world of Greece likewise doesn't
remain gray forever and as denial turns
to anger harsh splotches of red seep
into the surrounding environment you
slide emboldened with Reckless Fury down
a steep slope into an unforgiving desert
ruins streak these maroon Sands the
jutting aspires like the tips of Spears
left over from some ancient battle
storms also sweep through this region
watercolor swirls of blood red that make
it wise to seek shelter yet critically
the gain gives you the option to face
these storms headon and though you'll
inevitably be blown backwards it's
difficult to resist the temptation to
charge blindly forward and become angry
at the world
itself the game Hollow Knight similarly
encourages you to think combatively with
its punishing difficulty and aggressive
enemies the game makes it feel like it's
you against the world set in the Fallen
Kingdom of honest Hollow Knight's
ecosystem is plagued by a supernatural
illness known simply as the infection an
apocalyptic epidemic that manifests in
the form of rageful insects and great
puls of disease the background design
can make the entire world feel like a
kind of infection an unwanted growth
upon a long dead exoskeleton yet Hollow
Knight is also full of quiet expressions
of endurance perseverance even in the
grimmest environments though nominally a
game about violence I think it's also a
game about rebirth and how Beauty can
emerge in the toughest conditions in the
second stage of Greece you can encounter
in the shelters creatures living inside
chunks of ruins like the Dennison of
hollow Knight one could interpret these
life forms which come in all shapes and
sizes as an infections unwanted
parasites plaguing the corpse of A Lost
Civilization but there's also something
poignant here a testate to adaptability
in the face of adversity one that can
help you appreciate the value of knowing
when to take shelter perhaps a version
of the world has perished but if you let
go of your anger you can see that new
life has taken
root with the protagonist anger
subsiding the world transforms in an
eruption of green enormous Vines snake
across the landscape leading down far
below another layer of clouds to a vast
inviting Forest your grief has now
entered the bargaining stage and is easy
to feel like your Sorrows will no longer
shape the world that there will be no
traces of decay in this landscape yet
even in the midst of the forest the
shells of abandoned buildings still
remain the remnants overrun with
encroaching plant
life how should we feel when we see
cities is reclaimed by Nature it's a
question that was on my mind a lot when
I played Cloud Gardens a peaceful
gardening simulator crossed with a
dystopian landscape Builder I guess in
this game you help plants swallow up the
wreckage of humanity and activity that
elicits complicated emotions on the one
hand Cloud Gardens has a Charming voxal
aesthetic that makes turning decrepid
cityscapes into bastions of Life quite
satisfying but on the other hand well
there's definitely no sign of living
people in these
landscapes in his book the world without
us American journalist Alan wisman
explores what would theoretically happen
to human structures and objects if we
all suddenly disappeared and the answer
for the most part is that nature would
erase all traces of humanity extremely
quickly most buildings would be gone in
just a few hundred years certain
Plastics and metals would linger a
little longer
but not forever on a geological time
scale our built environments would be
gone in the blink of an eye there's a
kind of mental bargaining that goes on
when I try to decide how such facts make
me feel is it comforting to know that
new life would grow from the skeleton of
humanity if our species were to go
extinct or is it terrifying to imagine
being forgotten so
easily there are no other humans left in
the forest of Greece but there is a
little robot
who you fittingly have to literally
bargain with to find a way out of the
woods it's a sweet change of pace from
your lonesome travels yet something
about the way the robot knows all the
ins and outs of the forest can make you
feel like it belongs in this reborn
World in a way that you just don't the
world you knew is gone and no amount of
bargaining will change
that as the protagonist floats once more
in the palm of the person she lost the
landscape changes a fourth time time and
the long Melancholy of sadness begins
this stage of grief is represented
unsurprisingly by shades of blue rain
begins to fall like teardrops as you
strike out through a flooded watercolor
landscape yet while the surface of this
region is gloomy if you dive under the
waters you'll find a thriving ecosystem
of fish it's a jarring transition how
can this dead world a world in the wake
of a Calamity be so full of life
I don't think I've ever seen a setting
more vibrant than the one in abzu a game
where you steer a diver through gorgeous
undersea environments the ecosystem is
just overflowing with movement I
genuinely don't even know how it's
possible for a title from 2016 to
simulate this many schools of fish at a
time if you just stop the camera
anywhere the sheer amount of marine life
that will swim by is just insane it's
all so kinetic so Interactive Ive so
full of Vitality I don't know that
there's ever been a world more
emphatically alive than this one and yet
the world of abzu is haunted by Death
from early in the game you can stumble
upon murals from a doomed civilization
each fragment tells of a culture that
fell of a people whose memory is lost to
the waves their crumbling Halls now home
to the creatures of the deep there are
ruins in the ocean of Greece as well
sunken temples over grown with forests
of coral it reminds me of the second
stage of a whale fall where Groves of
life forms known as zombie worms spread
their Roots into the bones they pick the
skeleton completely clean making it hard
to imagine the animal as it once was but
there's a moment in abzu that conveys
the Splendor of a living whale better
than perhaps any other piece of media it
is at first a tranquil moment where you
swim with a mother and calf through the
open ocean and as you swim an entire pot
of whales joins your dive opening their
mouths wide to take huge gulps of krill
and then they swim on and you think the
moment is over until another pot of
whales even larger than the first comes
in from the other direction and before
you even have a chance to fully process
the site this happens a blue whale
emerges from off screen its eye right
next to you just staring and and then
the camera pulls all the way back and
you realize you're in the midst of
another pod and they all start spinning
through the depths brimming with life
and majesty and then at last this pod
departs as well and you realize you've
accidentally traveled all the way down
to the very bottom of the ocean and what
you find down here is a vast Boneyard of
whales forgotten on the sea Flor it's a
real tonal shift that can be read as
pessimistic but I think that would be
doing this moment to disservice because
even though these skeletons are picked
clean that doesn't mean they're lifeless
in the third and final stage of a whale
fall the bones appear deserted but
they're actually full of bacteria that
provide vital sulfides to the
surrounding ecosystem other forms of
life can flourish around a whale fall
fall for up to half a century sometimes
longer than the lifespan of the whales
themselves maybe the biion network of
abzu is built upon remains but it's
likely because of these remains that so
much life has gathered in one place even
in the best of circumstances however the
presence of any skeleton implies a cause
of death for worlds this typically means
some kind of apocalyptic event the sort
of big destructive moment that disaster
movies love to show us in gratuitous
detail I think it's important therefore
that you never see the Calamity that
sank the civilization in abzu you also
never learn what emptied the world in
Cloud Gardens or made the cursed lands
in Shadow of the Colossus you know
cursed even Greece which is about the
passing of a specific person as much as
the world never gives us any insight
into the demise itself in the context of
these narratives it doesn't really
matter what matters is what happens
next if any force in Greece could be
labeled apocalyptic it would be the
tendrils of shadow that haunt the
protagonist throughout their Journey
likely a representation of grief's most
destructive Tendencies this Darkness
constantly threatens to overwhelm the
main character like sorrow itself it
knows No Boundaries following you into
any environment in one underwater
section it becomes a giant eel that
pursues you through the tight corridors
in one of the tensest chase scenes I've
ever witnessed like death it seems
inescapable able to split itself into
two to cut off your Escape or transform
into a thousand little eels that chase
you you into the
Blackness one of the grimmest Dead
worlds I've seen is there will come soft
rains a 1984 Soviet animated short film
based on a ray Bradberry story of the
same name the narrative follows the
automatic systems of a house continuing
their pre-programmed daily routines
despite the fact the people of the house
are ashes it is revealed that this
building is the last one standing on a
planet that has otherwise been
obliterated by nuclear war the title for
there will come soft rains comes from a
poem by Sarah Teasdale which the house
recites part of at the end of the story
not one would mind neither bird nor tree
if mankind perish utterly and spring
herself when she woke at dawn would
scarcely know that we were gone though
not exactly uplifting this poem like
bradberry's short story is more tranquil
than the animated short I think there is
a kind of comfort one can take in this
idea of nature continuing on without us
particularly in 1918 when the poem was
written against the backdrop of the
first world war the poem and many of the
games in this video imply that if a
version of the world comes to an end
another will take its
place even in the darkness there is
light the very last color of Grease is
an Illuminating shade of yellow
representing the stage of acceptance
significantly however this final stage
does not return the world to a pre-
ruined State the architecture though
brighter is still withered and overgrown
with plants acceptance doesn't mean
returning to the way things were just
recognizing them as they are I don't
think any game exemplifies this concept
better than Sable the final title I want
to discuss today set within a harsh
desert Sable has on the surface the most
conventionally desolate post-apocalyptic
World in this entire video but it is not
to a remarkable degree a game interested
in mourning the past none of the people
you speak to are wistful of Ages gone or
lamenting the Desolation that surrounds
them though there isn't as much wildlife
in this land as most of the other games
in this video people Delight in the
animals they have all the more
everyone's satisfaction presumably is
because so much time has passed no one
remembers the way things used to be the
world has mourned and now it has moved
on indeed as a Coming of Age story
saap's narrative is deeply focused on
the future on what's waiting over the
next
Horizon I think it's fitting that the
largest structure in Sable is a set of
ruins nicknamed the whale implied to
have once been part of an Interstellar
ship these ruins have been pulled apart
for building materials to make new
houses likewise there are theories that
there is actually a secret for fourth
stage to whale Falls where their
skeleton provides a structure for new
coral reefs since scientists have only
been researching whale Falls for a few
decades it's currently unknown how far
into the future this stage could sustain
life is a whf really dead I mean
certainly the whale is dead that
original life form will never swim again
no matter how positive we want to be
about its role in the circle of
life I don't want to trivialize the idea
of a dead world not all these games
leave you feeling uplifted and not all
of them should acceptance isn't about
feeling happy forever it just means an
acknowledgement of a loss and for all
their beauty these worlds are tragic
there is grief here just as there are
moments of delight these worlds have
died and the world lives
on and as always thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next
video